hey guys welcome back to planet coaster
today I will finish the last buildings
of the main streets mostly add some
details to the Main Street to actually
make it come alive and also add one more
Japanese building though I do have to
say beforehand I have to make a lot of
concessions about what I would add to
the park to finish it because I am
really running out of time for the
second alpha and I really want to get it
done and upload it before the second
alpha comes out so there isn't really a
lot that I still had time to do but one
of the things which I really wanted to
do is obviously to finish the main
streets and finish some of the areas
which currently have like some smaller
unfinished parts more or less in the
middle of it which goes for the main
streets the ring of arches around the
Roman triumphal arch things like that
aside from that though this will be the
last sort of real episode in which our
work on just a main standalone scenery
and the next episode will just be one
last roundup just to quickly get that in
and be able to finish the park at least
in a presentable state
I hope this actually is one of the
reasons why I kind of do want to release
this park before alpha 2 comes out that
people are able to download this Park
initially make something out of it in
alpha 2 or at least download it in its
current States because there have been
some messages and I'm not entirely sure
if this is still right or if it's going
to be the case but there was a Q&A on
the forums of planet coaster recently
and I have seen some messages that due
to the new rotation of objects in alpha
2 which by the way is absolutely amazing
but that's beside the point it might be
possible that if you open all the parks
made from alpha 1 and alpha 2 that the
rotation of certain objects is just
gonna completely be weird and given the
amount of detail in this park and the
amount of strange rotations that many of
the objects in this park do use I do
kind of fear that it's not gonna work in
alpha 2 which is one of the extra
reasons now I guess that I really want
to get this out really soon and also why
I have this enormous planet coaster sort
of marathon at the moment as opposed to
any of the other
I've been playing anyway just a very
small background on this building this
building is actually somewhat inspired
by some Austrian architecture in general
it's hard to really see it since most of
these buildings do have many different
styles at the same time by especially
just wanted to mess with some more
decorations around the windows
especially with that decoration piece
with the with the rendered walls which
kind of makes it look more like these
these almost these paintings or render
decorations around Austrian buildings
and again a little experiment to get a
little bit more interesting little
railing on top of the building and on
top of the facade just to make it look
like a nice building - more or less
coming to the park with and transition
from the entrance building into the main
street because this is kind of an
awkward corner over here which I really
thought the most easy way to go about
doing it would be just to fill it up
with foliage which we just probably make
it a bit more interesting but there is
like a real disconnection I feel between
the entrance and the main street which
I'm sort of on the fence about at once
it feels somewhat good to have that
disconnection between it and to really
make the Main Street stand on its own
but it doesn't really you know it is it
would be nice to have that connection as
well much like you would see in a Disney
park with having some pretty main
buildings in the first Plaza as well
whereas over here the first plaza isn't
really much of an interesting plaza it's
just the area which you enter the park
in but aside from that it really doesn't
have any function and the main sort of
area and draw to this park and to this
Main Street is really the second Plaza
with the fountain in the middle of it
hence why this is also sort of and why
yeah the the Main Street is quite
distance from the park entrance as well
and most in most importantly I just
really wanted to make that one sight
line from the entrance of the park into
the second plaza of the main street
where you can see that tower looming
over the rest of the Main Street as a
good weenie I just wanted to keep that
as a main theme throughout this main
street not go too overboard especially
also since it is a very organic park at
least in the rest of the layout of the
park it doesn't have much of a Disney
style layout where it really has a plant
layout with a sort of central part to it
it's just sort of sprawls around the
park everywhere and the main street I
hope more or less reflect that with a
less straight Main Street and more one
that has a more sort of natural city
development look to it and the last
building a ladder over here or the last
two buildings I should say though the
building on the right here isn't really
too much of a special building I did
want to add a quick new addition as a
shop in there just to have a few more
actual shops that work just because it's
nice to add those but it's not really
big it's just a simple town house much
like the other town houses I have so far
and the corner building is actually
going to be quite similar to the other
corner buildings in the main street it's
sort of like there are three sort of
main corner buildings and all the three
entrances of the Main Street and they
all have the same sort of visual theme
especially with the red proof sign kind
of theme going on which you'll see in a
second though as I actually get to that
building but yeah I first kind of had to
do this small town house over here which
is more or less just better much like
every other single town house and also
one of the reasons why I kind of do like
to keep themes a little bit smaller than
this or to keep less buildings within
one theme it's obviously hard to avoid
it in a main street by always fine
there's this one point in like doing a
certain style or using certain objects
where you get really accustomed to it
and you don't really experiment as much
with it anymore you kind of get used to
it and while it like makes the entire
process a lot more
efficient I would say because you don't
really have to look for pieces or
experiment with things anymore it's
usually that point exactly where I want
to stop doing the theme and move on to
some new things just to try new things
because I there's that sort of like
tipping point where something becomes
like you get used to it and it becomes
more of a chore than it actually becomes
trying to be as creative as you can with
something that's why I try to move away
from certain styles if I've sort of done
them for quite a long time and I tickley
feel that this building right here was
more or less that tipping point for the
Main Street there was still one Japanese
building on which I really wanted to do
in a slightly different style which
you'll see at the end of this video
those are something about the Japanese
theme that I feel you can just keep
innovating it and just keep looking for
new ways to do it especially because
it's such a completely different style
from what the themes at the moment
actually meant for so you're really
forced to look for different ways to use
different objects and while I do realize
I've just talked about how after a while
I always get like sort of bored of a
certain theme and trying to find new
ways to do things I do always find that
the more you play a game in general not
specifically to anything the more you
kind of just expect just find these
little tricks and ways to do certain
things and these little uses for objects
and it's really that kind of thing which
helps you to become better at it and one
of the reasons why I feel there is
barely such a thing as being good at a
game right from the start if you look at
games like this and there's also no such
thing as I'm really bad at the moment so
I'll never get good at this because the
more you just play it in general the
more you you just kind of get used to
the way things work and the more you
find these little uses for objects not
to mention that people definitely draw
ideas from each other as well and then
they call it inspiration but you can
also just call it stealing if you really
wish probably also the best thing you
can probably do is just build things
even if you feel it's always good and
you can always learn from it I
definitely think there are some ways in
which this park has failed yup I am
going to have that discussion again
because it's actually quite important
vo for moving on because everybody fills
all the time and what this park is
mostly filled in which was kind of
predictable but still something I do
wanna take away for the next part is
even though it has a very organic layout
I don't feel it's quite as coherent as
it can be like some transitions just
don't really work well together and the
layout is in general just even more
messy than even an organic park should
be and that's definitely a main takeaway
like it's really focused on the
individual areas and sometimes even the
individual buildings but not so much
taking into consideration the fact that
it should be maybe built into an entire
park which should have like coherence
throughout the park in general which
wasn't my main aim but definitely
something I should take away from next
bikes as well though on a more like
smaller scope I'm definitely really
happy with how the plug turned out so
far and especially the reception it's
been getting seriously thank you guys
for that by the way so far it's been
really awesome and I know I get a lot of
questions about what I'm planning to do
with alpha-2 and I figured I can take a
little bit of time here just to talk
about it
I think I'll try and build a more Disney
style Park in terms of layouts at least
and I want to try some different themes
not the Alpine Japanese and Roman theme
which it's by the way a complete
coincidence that I happen to use both or
these three themes for both the
architects and the planet coaster series
it just happened to be that they seemed
most feasible with both games and in
their current States but with the new
park I kind of want to explore a more
fantasy ish theme in general so I'm
hoping to go into some western themes or
sci-fi themes or fantasy themes maybe a
medieval kind of thing it all kind of
just depends on what exactly the pieces
give but I want to go in more into like
the fantasy corner of doing things so
yeah it's gonna be more of the
otherworldly kind of themes on a small
scale and on a large scale I'm gonna try
to go for a more Disney style layouts
also I definitely want to abuse the hell
out of all the in rollercoasters not in
a bad way but seriously the
rollercoasters are absolutely amazing
and I'm really really impressed by them
so far definitely I think the best
roller coasters in any roller coaster
game ever if you don't count no limits
to as a game but as a program really and
I'm definitely also looking forward to
the terrain editing so I'll probably get
into a lot of terrain conforming
coasters especially terrain conforming
inverts might get into a Java nola
invert just to be a hipster about it or
an actual terrain conforming mine
terrain ish coasters things like that
definitely something I want to get into
but that's all for the next alpha and I
should also warn that I don't think I'll
get into it really quickly like I won't
start releasing videos of the new alpha
right away I really want to first kind
of get used to it got some ideas test
out certain things before I actually
start turning it into a park just to
make sure that I can actually get some
good things going and also I don't
really have a lot of time on my hands
recently and I might be sort of screwing
myself over even with how much time I'm
spending at the moment trying to get
krisily valley to be done before alpha 2
comes out so I'm not entirely sure how
quickly I'll actually gets to the second
Park but I will start a new park and
it's going to be something with
different themes and a different sort of
idea and concept altogether so that's
something to stay tuned for I suppose
anyway going back to the video itself I
just added a whole lot of detail to the
main street nothing really special just
a way to get it to look a little bit
more alive
have those those typical signs of life
there and I wanted to move on just do
one more Japanese building because this
space we still left empty and I didn't
quite want to put foliage over there it
didn't feel like a good way to round off
this area for one because it didn't seem
like a nice way to enter the area from
the main streets path because it would
just be foliage on one side and a
building on the other side and I kind of
just wanted to have you enter the
Japanese area with buildings and two
sides and also from the other
perspective so from the rollercoaster
perspective I found it to be
probably just a bit more interesting to
have this like almost Bulevar next to
the rollercoaster with buildings lined
alongside it just to make the area as a
whole a little bit more interesting and
then again I also wanted to experiment
with a few more ways of doing these
roofs because of all the Japanese areas
buildings I added recently none of them
actually have the very typical Japanese
sort of curved roof which isn't that
common in Japanese houses but I really
wanted to try and build one of these
more Japanese samurai ish houses and
also just try some new ways to get the
paper screens in and just mess with the
walls textures and things like that but
it's mostly all about the roofs which
you'll see in a second though aside from
that though it is a pretty simple
building and there's not really anything
special about it if this were an
alternate universe and we could have man
houses I would have loved to actually
put a man house in this building that's
also why I eventually ended up placing a
pretty large sort of backstage building
behind this the idea is that even though
this is a rather is small facade with a
like small wooden boardwalk next to it
it still has quite a lot of space behind
it for a potential like dark ride flat
ride at least and I would really figure
a Japanese mad house would have been
really awesome it's not on the game no
maybe that's a wink-wink nudge-nudge but
i don't think a japanese mad house is
the best thing to start recommending i
wouldn't exactly recommend it for the
game just wishful thinking and some who
would have loved to fit in here anyway
that is just majorly off-topic aside
from that no it has a pretty standard
sort of layouts with the oh my god I
completely forgot the name but like the
wooden thing along this site there where
you can sort of walk around with the
roof over the little wooden boardwalk
it's a little bit elevated as well and a
pretty simple sort of main part of the
building which is a bit higher than the
rest and has the actual curved roof
which turned out to be a little bit
harder to recreate than the other curved
roofs in the rest of the park and
especially a lot harder to do than just
the flat roofs because it doesn't just
involve slapping the the sandstone
pieces onto a curved roof because I
didn't quite want to have this exact
curved roof shape that the game gives
you I didn't want to get something a
little bit more smooth and more gentle
over curve so it eventually did end up
taking quite some time to get this
exactly right I did also catch the
interesting suggestion to try and
actually make the very typical Japanese
black sort of tiled roofs by using small
rocks and sinking them into the roof to
get that sort of dark black texture
going which I would have loved to do but
testing it it doesn't actually work
really well because the rocks are quite
large and you can't really hide them
under anything and it gets hard to
recreate the shape and it would have
also probably worked towards the lag in
this park already which I do have to say
one of the reasons also why I am ending
this bike and I've said this before but
at the moment is when I'm actually
really suffering the consequences I my
computer just can't really handle the
park anymore and I'm sort of on a steady
8 FPS but there's a tremendous amount of
click lag and UI is really slow as well
hence also why these time lapses are
still recorded at 12 times the speed but
especially in the next episode might be
a little bit slower than earlier
episodes just because it took longer to
do certain things and my computer really
can't handle much more of the park
anymore so yeah that's another one of
the reasons why I really couldn't finish
the park anymore though it was mainly
just a learning experience and I'm
really happy with how the parts are not
so far it's just one of the reasons why
I can't really go any further than what
I'm doing at the moment really anyway
that's the curved roof over there which
is I think just the best shaped roof at
least in the Japanese area which I have
so far it is kind of annoying to line
them all up and it is quite
time-consuming to do it in the exact way
which you want to but if anything it my
actually show of how incredibly flexible
this system already is and one of the
reasons why I'm also really looking
forward to the second alpha is for the
more free rotation that I mentioned
earlier in the video which might ruin
grizzly Valley but it's definitely an
amazing addition to the game because in
the future we won't really have to worry
about these different groups anymore to
get things to have specific rotations
because there will be three axis
rotation which is probably going to be a
really big game changer and definitely
something that will make things like
this not just easier but also going to
make a lot more possible because just by
being able to rotate all of these
different objects into all sorts of
different rotations you can make so many
more uses out of them than they
originally had and it's aside from that
though I think the Alpha 2 is also going
to give a lot of like building
improvements in these smaller pieces
that it's going to add it's going to add
some large oh [ __ ] that was a pan it's
going to add some large improvements in
building pieces but I think the most
important particularly the really small
pieces that the second Alpha will add
like small pillars and small blocks
which will be definitely very versatile
I think in making all sorts of different
things that the original themes of the
game don't have and allow for a lot more
creativity than we already have in the
game so far
so in short and this is something which
I'll get back to you in the next video
because the next video is more or less
going to be a closer of this park but
yeah in short I am really really looking
forward to alpha 2 and I also do have
some pretty big plans I'm just not sure
if I'll really be able to get to them
too soon but yeah I walk out back to
alpha 2 and hopefully it is going to be
really amazing but thank you guys for
watching this episode though I am just
about running out of time lapse at the
moment so I guess I'll see you guys
later
in the next episode though I'll just be
ahead in the time-lapse a little bit
since some of the finishing off will be
done off screen but I'll finish the park
in the next episode so hope to see you
then
you